cuando en 2014 vivimos un drama con el
uso hoy queremos pasar la página pero
seguimos alerta
hace 6 años esta ciudad de 26 mil
habitantes del sur en francia ha ocupado
las primeras planas en 2014 unos 20
jóvenes se fueron de línea para formar
parte del grupo estado islámico entre
ellos rafael a mar conocido como abu
ayub en síria seis años después de su
muerte de su padre no quiere que la
historia de su hijo sea olvidada
es importante que todos mantengan vivo
el recuerdo de estas tragedias porque
creo que la partida de los chicos
adoctrinados son tragedias absolutamente
inconmensurables para la nación como tal
ya que son la prueba de que hemos
fracasado de alguna manera
una idea que otros comparten con votar
aquel mi quien conocí a los jóvenes que
se fueron nos encontramos con él después
de aquella ola de partidas asiria en
2014 obviamente te sientes culpable te
dices que en algún momento cometiste un
error no hiciste tu trabajo como se
suponía que debía hacerlo y espero que
todo el mundo se sienta así porque al
final todos fallamos se recuperó el
lunes seis años después
inflexión
el profesor continuación vamos a por la
juventud la ciudad en la que las salidas
de 2014 dejaron una huella
los catalogaban sólo por vivir en lunes
tal y como se cataloga la gente cuando
vive en ciertos barrios pero como si
fuera la ciudad de lieja mismo así que
la gente la asociaba así me indigna oír
eso me entristece que la gente piense
que el lunes la ciudad del yihadismo
es una exageración si es una exageración
porque no es para nada así en su
asociación está hacker mix se concentró
en el deporte
aquí no hay religión ni comunidad
ni tampoco una receta milagrosa
no tengo las armas para luchar contra la
radicalización la única arma que tengo
es la educación lastimosamente siempre
habrá gente que se salga del camino y
por eso tenemos que permanecer
vigilantes entre los que se fueron en
2014 algunos asistieron a la mezquita
del un el jóvenes que estaban bajo la
influencia del imán de la época y que
asistían a reuniones clandestinas en la
mezquita afirman que han actuado en
contra de la radicalización la
institución está tratando de controlar
mejor lo que se dice dentro de sus muros
contrataron a un nuevo imán se quería
que fuera alguien que tuviera una
cultura francesa es decir alguien que
hubiera crecido en francia y que se
hubiera impregnado de la cultura
francesa eso es muy importante para
controlar lo que sucede en la mezquita
exactamente así que hoy aquí en la
mezquita de lunes no es posible reunirse
de dar instrucción religiosa sin pasar
por la oficina de la mezquita
qué
[Música]
durante dos años la alcaldía ha apostado
por la prevención líderes comunitarios
trabajadores sociales capacitados para
detectar signos de radicalización para
el alcalde hoy la amenaza si aparece
algo de otros tiempos
escucho lo que pasa en el terreno de la
boca de los educadores sociales de los
educadores deportivos de problemas son
ellos quienes hacen sonar las alarmas y
actualmente puedo asegurarles que no nos
llegan noticias de este tipo de
problemas es decir que hoy en día el
islamismo radical en él ya no es un
asunto importante no es un asunto de
todos los días significa que debe seguir
siendo una preocupación para un alcalde
tiene que vigilarlo al igual que todos
los alcaldes de francia
según los servicios de inteligencia no
ha habido informes de radicalización el
lunes desde hace dos años
lauren a mar vio a su hijo rafael
convertirse luego radicalizarse e irse
siria de un día a otro cuando tenía 21
años hoy está alerta cree que esta
vigilancia no es suficiente
ni siquiera podría garantizar que
cualquier vigilancia que se establezca o
se ponga en marcha puede evitarlos es
decir estuvimos alerta durante la
conversión de rafael durante cuatro años
día tras día intentamos mantener el
contacto y evitar la radicalización y la
estigmatización to see the gap as de
hoja de cher y christina gato y con su
cónyuge ya pagar seis años después de la
muerte de su nación siria todavía está
tratando de entender qué le pasó a
rafael lauren presentó una denuncia y
está esperando que la justicia responda
a sus preguntas